TikTok bills itself as “the last
sunny corner of the internet”
But many people see a dark side.
Beneath the app’s surface lies
incredibly advanced artificial
intelligence that has learned what
people like with stunning impact.
TikTok signed up 1 billion users
in half the time it took Facebook.
Facebook launched in 2004 and hit 1 billion users
in 2012, so took 8 years). TikTok, launched in
2016, reached the milestone in just five years,
in 2021 - can we show this on-screen simply?
The West has always accused China of
copying technological advances, but now,
Silicon Valley is rushing
to mimic the Chinese app.
In response to TikTok’s
short video format, YouTube
introduced Shorts. And Instagram released Reels.
Unlike Instagram, where your feed consists
of photos and videos from people you follow,
TikTok relies on a strategy
of recommendations first.
You find yourself watching videos from people
you never chose to watch, who you don’t follow.
It’s what TikTok believes will most appeal to you.
Imagine the effect of binging on an endless
stream of 15 or 30-second videos…for an
hour and a half a day - the average
amount of time users spend on TikTok.
That dopamine rush is addictive.
And, a study from the Technical University
of Denmark found that the constant stream
of information from social media can
shorten our attention span over time.
“...and that this effect occurs - not
only on social media - but also across
diverse domains including books, web
searches, movie popularity, and more.”
In other words, a shorter attention
span impacts every aspect of your life.
When was the last time you sat
through an entire movie at home?
Can you even bear to watch older
movies that are slower paced?
No Mr. Matuschek, it’s not for us.
Or worse: what happens when our society is
filled with people who lack the focus to
think things through over long periods or
complete projects that take a lot of time?
In the way that TV news in the seventies
shortened reports to 1 minute 30 seconds
to keep the attention of the television audience,
TikTok is now shortening our attention
span from minutes to seconds.
Anything longer isn’t worth our time, unless we’re
really, really interested in the subject matter.
Does a 30-minute YouTube video now feel
like an unbearably long documentary?
Our addiction to the screen is
literally damaging our brains.
Multiple studies have shown that
those addicted to gaming and the
internet have a reduced volume
of gray matter in their brain.
Gray matter has a large number of neurons present,
which allows it to process
information in the brain.
So, spending too much time on your phone is
literally causing your brain tissue to atrophy.
Much of the damage occurs in
the frontal lobe - the area
that largely determines success in life -
be it academics, career, or relationships.
Then there’s the issue of the quality
of the videos you’re watching.
There’s been a lot of talk lately
that TikTok in the US is different
from the version shown in China,
where TikTok is known as Douyin.
A user wrote on Quora that his TikTok feed “is
filled with teenagers doing stupid things.”
Whereas his Douyin feed is “filled with
self-improvement, photography, travel,
calligraphy, life hacks, trivia, interesting new
products, and of course, cute dog/cat videos.”
By the way, in China, those aged 14
and under are limited to using Douyin
for 40 minutes a day and are blocked
from using it between 10 pm to 6 am.
The differences between the two TikToks is stark,
as social media expert Tristan
Harris told 60 Minutes.
“...they make their domestic
version a spinach version of
TikTok, while they ship the opium
version to the rest of the world.”
Perhaps that speaks to the difference in career
aspirations of Chinese and American children.
In China, most kids dream
of becoming an astronaut.
In America, most kids aspire
to be social media influencers.
Toward the end of Donald Trump’s presidency, he
tried and failed to ban TikTok in the U.S. or
force the Beijing company that owns it, ByteDance,
to sell TikTok’s American arm to a domestic owner.
The most frequent criticism
of TikTok is privacy issues.
China can demand whatever information it
likes from companies based in its country.
A damning report from BuzzFeed
in June 2022 claimed “U.S. user
data was repeatedly accessed
from (TikTok staff in) China”
TikTok has always insisted that information
from the U.S. is stored in the U.S,
which right now is on the servers
of American company Oracle.
And at a recent New York Times event, its CEO
denied handing over Americans’ data to China.
No foreign government has
asked us for U.S. data before,
really they haven’t, and if
they did, we would say no.
But Washington isn’t buying it. In December,
lawmakers in the House and Senate
introduced legislation that would ban
TikTok in the U.S. after the FBI warned
it could be used by China for spying.
The Senate has voted to ban TikTok from all
government-issued phones. As of this video,
TikTok is growing exponentially.
It was the most downloaded app in
2021 and remains on top in 2022.
Although it may have started off as a dancing app,
it is increasingly becoming
a news source for Gen Z.
Like during Johnny Depp’s defamation
trial against his ex-wife Amber Heard.
My dog stepped on a bee
Newsthink does have a TikTok account,
where I hope to educate and enlighten
people…in a short span of time.
But…it’s exactly that short
span of time that’s problematic.
We constantly crave more and more
information in less and less time.
And THAT may one day, spell disaster.
TikTok is slowly becoming a news source.
There’s a lot of news these
days about climate change.
It will take a lot to end the crisis. And one
company is trying to tackle
it simply and effectively.
Wren is a website and app that makes it easy
for you to calculate your carbon footprint.
By answering a few questions about your lifestyle,
you can discover your carbon
footprint and how to reduce it.
You can make a monthly contribution. This will go
toward projects like this one which provides clean
cooking fuel to refugees in Uganda. You’ll receive
monthly updates on the projects you support.
Since Wrench launched in 2019, they’ve
sent over $1 million in funding to projects
planting trees, protecting rainforests,
and otherwise fighting the climate crisis.
You can offset your carbon
footprint today on Wren by
signing up with the custom link in my description.
The first 100 people who sign up will
have 10 extra trees planted in their name.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I'm Cindy Pom.